Trump's nominee for the Supreme Court
Brett Kavanaugh is being reinvestigated
about allegations of sexual assault but
during his confirmation hearing he faced
questions on another issue raging in
America for very long time that of
abortion some evangelical Christians and
conservatives want him to help overturn
Roe vs. Wade
that's the decision that made abortion
legal in the United States well our US
correspondent Cordelia Lynch has been
given pretty rare access to a clinic in
Oklahoma City where providers are deeply
concerned about the future and you may
find some of the images and content in
her report distressing in Oklahoma they
have to fly abortion providers in there
are only three clinics in the state and
just one for second trimester
pregnancies two weeks ago when I was
here the ones that I saw I mean two of
them were surgical doctor andreas
Chiaverini has a packed schedule and
she's taking us to see what it's like on
the inside
do you know the first day of your last
period this state has been restricting
access to abortion forcing women to
travel huge distances
some of them come from Texas Louisiana
Arkansas it's crazy and then they wait
seven hours because we just we can't
know like there's only more than 450,000
women at had abortion the work was made
possible by roe v wade and landmark
legal decision in the 1970s that fueled
decades of fierce debate the Supreme
Court today ruled that abortion is
completely a private matter to be
decided by mother and doctor in the
first three months of pregnancy 45 years
later Donald Trump is promising change
with a conservative judge that could
help overturn the ruling that may be the
dream of evangelical Christians but not
the majority of America and in
hard-pressed places like Oklahoma it
sparks fear
hello hi I'm dr. Shalini it's nice to
meet you dude alright so the situation
Oklahoma is literally what I recall like
at the level of a developing country our
work specifically in Oklahoma and in
Kansas you know it's the whim of the
legislature the whim of the legislature
and then also whoever is sitting in the
governor's mansion in the operating
rooms there are no easy decisions ok
honey I'm gonna feel me touch ok I'm
just gonna check your cervix here this
woman is 15 weeks pregnant good job
[Music]
what strikes you the most here is just
how busy it is demand is clearly high
many women have driven hours to get here
and some have spent weeks hanging on
trying to save enough money for the
procedure it can cost up to 2,000 pounds
this woman has traveled six hours from
another state
she says she's married and studying and
isn't ready to have a child at home she
found it near impossible to find help it
was very hard I called I believe about
10 clinics five in my town in another
five in another town next to ours and
they wouldn't give any information about
anything that comes talking about
abortion they would even be mean talking
about it but conservatives believe the
tide is turning in their favor
I think Oklahoma is a tough state to
access abortion representative Justin
Humphrey is pushing for men to have more
legal power I am very much opposed to
abortion and I think that you know
fathers should be given a say-so fathers
should be advice you know you ought to
at least have to advise a father and
give him an opportunity to have some
say-so
there is already deep stigma and
struggle attached to abortion in the
u.s. carved by religion race and money
in Jackson Mississippi some are so
desperate they're taking things into
their own hands and she was saying how
she was like if you start bleeding a
little too heavily things like that
denise is one of hundreds of thousands
of women in America who have attempted a
self-induced abortion at 16 she says an
older woman she knew gave her a herb to
take I kind of stopped beginning the day
that everything I finally came out and
then the fetus came out while I was in
the shower and I kind of just like just
like
I just looked at it mmm I picked it up
and put it in my wash cloth rag and I
walked outside I mean it was flanking my
dorms from the front of a graveyard so I
walked to the back through the apartment
area and I put it in this ditch over
there and just kind of goodbye my day
she was at boarding school and her
family were well known in the community
I felt dirty
and I felt exposed do you think more and
more people are resorting to
self-induced abortions yes I know people
who have used bleach and vodka I know
people who have tried to use herbs that
they just heard about on the internet
those highly dangerous choices could
kill them and they're potentially
breaking the law too many feel like
they're running out of options and that
the rights they do have could soon be
rewritten
but going it alone could easily prove to
be fatal
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Oklahoma City